It is almost the end
of our birthday celebration with Drewsie.
Well, Ross put on his party outfit for this last segment.
(audience laughs)
This, I would like, thank you for noticing,
this is my third change for you, Ms. Barrymore.
All right, it's your birthday, you deserve it.
I clocked every sweater you were wearing.
Thank you!
And this is definitely my favorite outfit.
I agree, I look great.
It's so you.
Thank you for noticing.
(audience laughs)
All right, and I'm doing, Drew,
you're going to freak out over this next gift, all right?
Because our girl Drew, you know, we know her,
she loves organizing, baskets and shelf liners,
she's a real party animal.
Matching little bowls for everything on her desk,
and her happy place is where?
Not Marie, guys, sorry, Marie Kondo is my happy place.
Yes!
And she's doing a collab with The Container Store.
Which we dorked out over on Drew's News.
Oh yeah!
You love The Container Store, and guess what, VFFs?
You are all getting a $150 credit at The Container Store!
(audience cheering and applauding)
Yay!
Happy Birthday!
Okay, we still have one more gift.
This one is for you though, Drew.
I wanna say hello to our final surprise.
Live from city hall, please welcome the mayor
of West Hollywood, California, Lindsey Horvath!
(audience cheers and applauds)
Hi!
Hi Ms., Madam Mayor, how are you?
I am great, it's an honor and a pleasure to be here
with you today to celebrate the one and only Drew Barrymore.
She grew up here, this is her hometown.
We know this is a place where she,
we hold her dear in our hearts,
and West Hollywood is just so, so proud of the success
that Drew has had.
And while many people know us for fabulous gay men,
I myself am partial to powerhouse women, so.
(Drew laughs)
(audience applauds)
And Mayor Horvath, I know there's a special reason
you wanted to be here for Drew's birthday,
and a special gift for her.
Can you tell us?
Yes, so we have a very official proclamation
to make today here in the city of West Hollywood.
Allow me to read.
Whereas Drew Barrymore,
who grew up on North Poinsettia Place in West Hollywood
is recognized as a celebrated actress, producer,
director, talk show host, and entrepreneur.
And whereas Ms. Barrymore has a special connection
to the city of West Hollywood.
Now therefore be it resolved that the city council
of the city of West Hollywood declare February 22nd, 2021,
Drew Barrymore Day in West Hollywood, California.
(Drew shrieks)
(audience claps and cheers)
It's your day!
Thank you, I.
I just officially had a heart attack.
All right, having your own day is great,
but there's even more.
Mayor Horvath, what else do you have for Drew?
Oh my God.
Today, we would like to bestow upon you, Ms. Barrymore,
a key to the city of West Hollywood.
Thank you for being such a wonderful ambassador
for our community.
(audience claps and cheers)
Happiest of happy birthdays.
Aw.
I love that you're in a top hat, giving me this,
so it feels just so, it really does feel "Wizard of Oz,"
thank you, Mayor Horvath.
You're so welcome.
I'm very grateful.
I loved growing up in West Hollywood.
It was such a interesting community to grow up in.
It was really open-minded and open-hearted,
and it set me up for success in life,
to accept people and care about them.
Ross.
What?
We forgot the cake.
Can we roll out the cake?
Without a cake.
(audience cheering and applauding)
Oh.
It's a pretty one.
Thank you, it's so beautiful.
Drew, you are loved.
You are loved, happy birthday.
And this is your show,
so you have to say goodbye.
D-Nice, I can't believe you are here.
What you did for all of us
(audience cheers)
when you started Club Quarantine made us feel
like everything was gonna be okay
when we were the most scared.
So thank you.
(audience cheers and applauds)
We love you, Drew.
I hope you just are soaking it in.
I hope you absorb it when you lay your head down
in bed tonight, I hope all these memories come rushing back,
and you just really feel it,
because it's your birthday.
Every day is Drew Barrymore Day.
(Ross laughs)
Definitely the best day of my life.
And I really just wanna say thank you to Chris,
and Amber, and Jason, and Marianne, and Robin, and Liam,
Mr. Daniel, and everyone I do this show with, like,
literally, I wish I could be cooler
and keep it together, but I can't.
I love you guys so much.
(audience cheers and claps)
I don't know how I will ever pay this back,
but I will live my life paying it forward.
Aw.
Thanks, you guys.
(audience applauds and cheers)
♪ Celebrate good times, come on ♪
♪ Celebrate ♪
♪ Let's celebrate ♪
(upbeat rock music)
♪ Oh-oh, oh-oh ♪